et secours des gonzesses et mettons la
jactance mal frappe qui sentit phl dans
le gourbi de la jasse finances
franchouillard super alphonse était en
train de mater dans loucedé faudrait
bien jacques t1 - avec toi là commença
vote d'académie française c'est pour
quand
bah écoute j avais gamberger à
l'académie française seulement
maintenant qu'il ya des gonzesses samedi
plus rien largo ça remonte à la nuit des
temps facile et le premier le premier
moment où on a littérairement de l'argot
spec françois villon
c'est avec françois villon et un
document qui date du procès des
coquillards ou un des voyous de la bande
des coquillards qui s'appelait dimanche
le loup balance
il mange le morceau comme on est et en
mangeant un morceau il donne le premier
langage codé des coquilles à mes potes à
la lourde font le cerf j'ai fait
bordures et les cabestros il est l'art
du cloporte métamorphosé d'auvers j'ai
jeté la cerise et les baies cas de
l'hosto alors à différentes reprises
dans l'histoire on a des documents
écrits jusqu'au 19ème siècle après le
19e siècle ça va devenir bien plus
important mais jusque là ça reste le
langage de la cour des miracles
un langage secret et seuls les truands
les voyous le bas
c'est comme ça c'est un peu dans la
luxure laisse bord tu as vu bull thema
plus les scissions ça comme tu es ma
soeur pour qu'à rome pour leur coûter
entendons c'est ouais ouais laisse béton
ya tellement de marché maintenant les
mots de la drogue rejoint par exemple il
tape un jouet personne n'aurait compris
il y à il ya cinq ans bien des
mouvements des moucherons avant tout
même dans le verlan il ya une création
de par rapport à chaque mec tu mets les
mots d'argot bon c'est les mots que tout
le monde connaît je vais dire ils
viennent de partout et nulle part qu'il
n'y a pas une source
y'a pas une origine purgé dix ans ce ne
soit plus un secret dont se servent
d'entre eux certaines catégories
sociales alors ça sert à quoi s'exprimer
comme vous exprimer pour rester entre
nous rester entre nous et c'est une
façon le furent un peu les autres mais
les autres on les connaît pas c'est une
façon de rester sur soi même
en général dans l'extension rêviez en
usage dans certaines catégories sauce et
cabossé bien je veux dire en littérature
pour les romans policiers pour les gens
qui font du ciné c'est bien je dirais ça
prend ça prend du style me dire à
l'échelle des lascars comme mes potes
comme moi bon sang d'un ou la rouille et
comme ça elle est dans notre tête il est
dans la rue et dans les murs
il est sur la gueule des frites il est
il est là on est malheureux toi voilà je
fais peut penser que l'argot des des
zonards des loulous des rockers
d'aujourd'hui entre dans l'histoire
c'est à dire il y aura des mots il y
aura les mots les mots les plus les plus
caractéristiques les plus marrants les
qui parle le mieux à l'oreille seront
ceux qui rentreront dans l'histoire
quand je parle avec un mec qui rafla
logo j'essaye de lui parler le plus
français possible mais sauf quand on
insulte quoi mais
quand je parle avec mes copains je parle
en argot quand je chante je chante en
mon langage quoi je vais essayer de lui
ni de l'entretenir ni deux ni de des
limiers niveau bourthayre langage que
j'ai appris mon déjà quand j'étais môme
et puis après quand j'ai fréquenté les
lycées les écoles
j'ai un peu perdu mais après quand j'ai
arrêté mes études à 16 bat léger j'ai
commencé à bosser donc à fréquenter un
peu la rue il était coursier gt et
possédant des boutiques
chauffeur-livreur comme ça j'ai commencé
à faire monter les bistrots et la rue
les jeunes et puis la banlieue c'est là
ça mais en mieux c'est un langage une
expression qui te quitte plus qu'il ne
quittera plus bas je crois pas pour toi
la rose et c'est pas bidon tu crois
qu'on parlera toujours larbaud pour moi
il n'y a plus qu'une seule façon de dire
qu'un truc et c'est formidable c'est un
essai derrière son père et ça baigne
c'est cool ça craint pas je vais pas
employer les mots du dictionnaire pour
dire qu'un truc et super g pas dire
c'est merveilleux c'est extraordinaire
parce que me plaît je dis ça mange c'est
super sur la tête me débecte je dis pas
cette chose me déplaît je pourrai jamais
dire ça gérer ça me gonfle toujours je
préfère me la faire grâce et crapuleuse
sap est un guignol parmi les grosses
tranches des balourds de babi yar bomba
j'arrête un peu les frais et puis je
casse la g
[Musique]